there's a new twist in the divorce
battle between Kristin Cavallari and Jay
Cutler it's Kristin's former best friend
who was stirring the pot Kelly was in my
inner circle she was one of my people
she was accused of having an affair with
Jay last season of the show I haven't
talked to her I have not spoken to her
after so much divorce drama already
could it be
is that Kristin's estranged husband Jay
Cutler with Kristin's former BFF Kelly
Henderson posted the pic on Instagram
and the mystery man in the shot is
wearing a beaded bracelet similar to the
ones Jay where's upset fans were quick
to point out how super tight Kristin and
Kelly were before the affair rumor
another big storyline was obviously your
friendship with Kelly yeah so fun for me
to help kelly navigate this whole dating
world Kristin offered single Kelly
dating advice and her husband a former
NFL quarterback appeared on Kelly's
podcast what's your favorite sexual
position I think we experiment with many
different ones I think just a couple
friends that Jay really loves and Kelly
is one of them as for that rumored
affair well Jay says it never happened
and Kelly broke down in tears denying it
on very Cavalieri stupid thing ever so
back to that photo a source tells et no
that is absolutely not Jay also the
bracelet doesn't match any we've seen
him where speculation online is that
Kelly is just thirsty and looking for
more Instagram followers by making it
seem like that could be Jay
[Applause]
the estranged couples empire is worth a
reported sixty million dollars but the
big issue really hasn't been money or
cheating rumors but the kids in new
court documents just filed today Kristen
and Jay have agreed to a permanent
parenting plan Kristen was able to buy a
new house not far from their current
home and the two realized they need to
remain a solid front for the children
[Music]